Subspace spend by the igen vectors corresponding to non- negative IG values and Pi 1 is projection onto the space
expanded by the igon vectors corresponding to negative IG values these are indeed projections and
if we add them together we get the identity Matrix because the igen vectors S 0 through S N minus one form an
orthonormal basis if this measurement is performed in the situation at hand meaning that
the state being measured is row 0 with probability p 0 and Row one with probability P1 then it turns out that
the probability of a correct identification has a pretty simple formula in terms of the igen values Lambda 0 through Lambda n minus
one I won't go through the details of the calculation in this video you can consult the written content Linked In the video description if you're
interested or see if you can convince yourself that this formula is indeed correct we can also Express this
probability using a matrix Norm commonly called the trace Norm it's a similar notation to the ukian norm for vectors
except that we have a subscript of a one to indicate that it's the trace Norm the trace Norm is very important and it's
very commonly encountered in Quantum Computing but I won't say too much more about it in this lesson one way to
define it for herian matrices is that it's the sum of the absolute values of the igen values and so you can think
about this second equality as following directly from that definition the trace arm can also be
defined in other ways that are more General and we'll encounter the tracor again in the next lesson this is in fact
the best that you can do this measurement is optimal assuming your goal is to maximize the chance of a correct
guess that fact is sometimes called the hellstrom Holo theorem and it's also sometimes just called hellstrom's
theorem so you can't beat this measurement in terms of correctness probability and it's nice because
there's a simple recipe for the measurement itself and an exact formula for the correctness probability in terms of the trace
Norm the trace Norm is often used as a way of measuring the observable difference between density matrices for
precisely this reason and when people refer to the trace distance between States they're typically referring to
one half times the trace Norm of the difference between the two density matrices which here corresponds to the case where p 0 and P1 are both 1/2 which
is a natural case to consider Quantum State discrimination for two states is optimally solved by
the heal from measurement for which we have a simple recipe and a simple formula for the correctness
probability so what happens when we want to discriminate among three or more States in this case we don't have a
formula in general for an optimal choice of a measurement or a simple expression for the maximum probability of
correctness it is however possible to find a good approximation of an optimal measurement with the help of a computer
and in particular that can be done using a really fascinating and Powerful optimization technique known as semi-definite programming but it's not
something that you can feasibly Implement using a pencil and a piece of paper for instance on the other hand if somebody
gives you a description of a measurement and they claim to you that this measurement is optimal for a Quantum State discrimination task then it
actually is very easy to either verify or falsify that claim and that could be done using the so-called Holo Yan
Kennedy LAX conditions I won't explain what they are in this video but they are simple conditions and it's pretty cool
that this is possible here's an example which connects back to the tetrahedral states
that we saw earlier in the lesson suppose we're giving one of these four states selected at random with
probability one quarter for each one and our goal is to determine which state that we're given it's not surprising perhaps but
the best choice you can make for a measurement to do this is the tetrahedral measurement you can't always do
something like this for an arbitrary collection of pure States but because of the symmetries involved here this does
work and we actually get a valid measurement and through the Holo un Kennedy LAX conditions that I mentioned
a few moments AG ago it turns out to be quite straightforward to prove that this is indeed an optimal choice of a
measurement specifically what happens here is that the measurement is always correct with probability 1/2 which isn't
bad because there are four Alternatives so the probability of a correct guess is twice as good as random guessing and it
happens to be the best that you can do for these states now I'll say just a little bit more about Quantum State tomography
where we have many independent copies of an unknown Quantum state and the goal is to find an approximation of the density Matrix that describes
that state there are actually several different variants of this problem that depend on your assumptions and in
particular on what sorts of measurements you allow for instance we could demand that each system is measured individually and
the results are combined somehow to arrive at a description of the density Matrix or we could allow all of the
systems to be measured together as a single compound system which is much better in theory but it's also much more
demanding from a technological standpoint in addition to the choices one makes for the measurements there's
also an important consideration which is how to reconstruct a description of the density Matrix from whatever data you
get from the measurements I won't go into details about this my point is simply to suggest
that Quantum State tomography is really more of an umbrella concept having many different variants as opposed to being a
single procedure there's been a great deal of research into this problem including some fairly
recent breakthrough results that connect the number of copies n to the accuracy of the approximation that can be obtained and it continues to be an
interesting and active area of research to finish off the lesson let's take a look at Quantum State tomography
for cubits and how we can do it so let's suppose that row is a density Matrix representing a state of a
single Cubit and X1 through xn are cubits that have all been independently prepared in the state row and for the
sake of this discussion let's assume that n is large what we can do is to divide the
systems into three roughly equal piles and for the first pile we'll perform a measurement with respect to the plus
minus basis for each outcome corresponding to plus we'll score plus one and for each
outcome corresponding to minus we'll score minus one a more succinct way to describe this measure
is that it's a poly X measurement because the plus and minus states are IG vectors of the poly X Matrix and the
corresponding igen values are plus one and minus one and in fact that's also a much more common way to describe it and